Iron Man 2 the sequel to one the biggest
superhero films that ever came out at
the end of the last Iron Man movie we
see a superhero do something that I
don't think I've ever seen a superhero
do in a movie he reveals his secret
identity to the world when does that
ever happen it's always to a love
interest or a close friend or something
like that whoever just admits to the
world that they're a superhero it's
something I've never seen before and got
me really excited for the sequel because
you would think wow this is going to go
places we've never seen a superhero
movie go before and in some respects it
does we see the life of a superhero if
he was a celebrity Tony Stark has taken
the law into his own hands as flying
around the world and stopping evil
wherever he sees and the government kind
of a confusing way is powerless to stop
it he's more popular than ever everybody
loves him and of course he has his
vengeful haters
Mickey Rourke is a villain who vows
vengeance against Tony Stark because of
some wrongdoing that his father did in
the past
he attaches these electric ropes to his
hands and suddenly he's one hell of a
badass bump but that's not the only
thing going wrong Tony's heart is slowly
giving out because of the electronic
device that he's using to keep him alive
has put so eloquently the device that's
keeping him alive is also slowly killing
it on top of that he's upgraded Pepper
Potts to take over his business a new
bodyguard named Black Widow plait
famously now by Scarlett Johansson
enters the mix and another big
corporation wants to take down Stark by
teaming up with work and creating even
better war machines in fact one of them
is even called war machine when this
film came out people hated it all they
could do is talk about how god-awful it
was now don't get me wrong it still did
really good at the box office but
everybody just despised the hell of them
does the film deserve such a bashing
can do but I don't know if it deserve
quite as much as a gap I guess I'll talk
about the good stuff first it does show
kind of the price of celebrity Tony of
course loves the attention but he
realizes that he can't escape himself no
matter how hard he parties or gets drunk
all his misery is always waiting there
for him except now it's in public and
everybody can see it when he gets in a
fight with a best friend suddenly it
makes news and it makes it even harder
for him to figure out how to solve his
problems
Mickey Rourke as well is a great choice
for a villain he has a wonderful boys he
as a perfect look he has the strength he
just came off of a huge hit movie it's
an ideal choice but this does all build
up to the biggest problem with the movie
it goes nowhere
remember that problem with Tony's heart
you go cut that out and not miss
anything
you know how Mickey Rourke is spending
most of the movie building these
incredible weapons it's only around a
few minutes at the end he'll you know
how Mickey Rourke is supposed to be the
villain in this you barely see them in
fact the main bad guy is just some
asshole in a suit wait do we already
have some asshole in the suit in the
last movie yeah we get it big business
bad but come on we just dealt with this
guy when there is fighting in the movie
it doesn't really connect to anything
that big or epic Ironman fights with his
friend well ok looks cool but who cares
would it be cool those Mickey Rourke
there I mean they're friends fighting we
know they're gonna make up we know
they're gonna figure things out
why are we spending so much time seeing
them fight at a party remember how stark
upgraded Pepper Potts to run the company
she doesn't like it she turns it down
after a while
okay well what's the point of that then
there's a lot of time dedicated to Tony
and remembering his father what a jerk
he was only to figure out he wasn't
really that much of a jerk okay what did
that add Tony still acts like a jerk and
not the fun kind of jerk just a jerk
jerk he cos drunken keeps telling
everybody that despite what they think
he knows what he's doing but he doesn't
he clearly doesn't know what he's doing
and it's not fun to watch in the first
film he did jerky things but he still
came around to using his brilliant mind
he utilized stuff he was resourceful
here all the times he reassures people
that he knows what he's doing it never
comes back into play
thank God they tackle Black Widow a lot
better in the future because she's kind
of a waste of character here so yeah the
film does have a lot of problems and in
the end probably doesn't really work but
the strength of it does still come from
the cool stuff that we like to see in an
Iron Man movie we like to see the
technology we like to see the one-liners
and again we like to see Robert Downey
jr. doing the role that redefined him
even when he's being such a pain in the
ass he is still so funny and so
enjoyable to watch which is why it's
such a letdown when you find out that he
actually doesn't know as much as he's
letting on and that he is just getting
drunk and acting like an ass so I don't
know I guess it's bad but I still think
there's some really neat things in there
they haven't been done yet like tackling
the celebrity of a superhero who
revealed himself the technology is upped
a little bit and yeah you do kind of see
Iron Man doing the typical Iron Man
stuff there's just not as much as you
would like in the end it just kind of
feels like a distraction to introduce a
few other elements in between Marvel
movies I guess I feel a little bad for
it because everybody praised what a
masterpiece the first movie was and yeah
it's good it's well done but it had
problems too and everyone seems to
forget that when they look at this one
it doesn't work as a whole but I don't
think it's as bad as everybody else
built it up to be and I guess we kind of
know that there's more Iron Man movies
on the way anyway so it's not like this
is the last one we would ever see now
how would that one fare up well we'll
get to that when we get to that but for
this one it's probably the perfect
definition of close but no explode
you